going out of bounds if you don't all
can't check for it or if you'll hardware
doesn't signal it to you can be really
really embarrassing because all sorts of
dangerous situations can happen perhaps
the most easy one to understand is that
yes if you add together two positive
numbers that are too big they're going
to come out looking like a negative
number the the overflow situation will
propagate into the sign bit you add
together two things which you've got a
zero on the left saying clearly they're
positive when the whole thing overflows
you end up with the answer having a one
in the sign bit so it's looking negative
if you for example haven't had a digital
radio altimeter which was absolutely
sure that you were at 30,000 feet and
then suddenly found that it to run out
of bits and oh dear you've added
together the latest increments in height
course you've climbed a bit and oh dear
you seem to be 60 fathoms deep under the
sea things can get very very
embarrassing indeed if other hardware
that controls your engine or your flaps
relies absolutely on this thing being
correct I'm going to describe to you in
three different ways how you might
tackle doing negative numbers
whichever notation you use it turns out
to be handy to keep the right-hand side
of your bit pattern as you look at it
the actual magnitude of the number and
save the leftmost bit as you're looking
at it for denoting the sign and almost
universally it will be if that's
so-called sign bit as it's now called
is zero then it denotes a positive
number if it's a 1 it's going to denote
a negative number so roughly speaking if
you think about that 0 and 1 signaling
the sign that leaves you 3 bits left for
the actual size of the number be it
positive or negative well in 3 bits you
can hold anything from 0 to 7 so roughly
what one is saying is that if we have a
range of numbers that goes from plus 7
to minus 7 if you think about it that's
14 to
from numbers one to seven positive one
to seven negative fourteen different
numbers but in four bits we can
accommodate 16 numbers tooth power 4 is
16 naught to 15 in unsigned
so where's the other two gone we've
allocated for teams to all the other two
are real trouble causes because what
tends to happen in your naive approach
to this which we'll do in a minute is
those two missing numbers converge or
wanting to be 0 so you end up with plus
0 and minus a 0 and that is a pain you
start off with 0 4 zeros here 4 plus 0
if you put a 1 in the sign bit position
but leave the others to 0 then of course
you've got minus 0 what could be more
nightmarish if you're trying to design a
binary adder circuit to say oh we're not
just got to check 4 plus 0 we gotta
check 4 minus 0 okay and all the rest it
just follow exactly like that look 0 0 0
1 is plus 1 so what would minus 1 be
same as plus 1 nor not 1 but put a 1 to
denote negative at the left-hand side
and that works all the way in this sign
and magnitude notation the example I'm
going to take in all three of these
notations I'll be covering is just
simply this plus 7 and add on minus 3 to
it in other words it's 7 take away 3 the
answers got before now where do we get
to it's sign and magnitude we write down
plus 7 then we write down 1 0 1 1 don't
forget this is now the sign bit it's
special the note 1 1 2 and the 1 is 3
but the one in the sign bit position
says I'm trying to do 7 minus 3 your
hardware man then start saying look I've
got to build some binary logic circuitry
to do this and what I want is just to do
simple binary additions with carries
even though it's a subtraction I don't
care you've told me you denote in a
negative number I want to do simple
binary additions of ones and laws and I
want the answer to drop out just
magically 2
plus four will it not a chance I'm going
to say if you just add them what would
happen you get 1 plus 1 is 0 and carry 1
1 + 1 + 1 we now know you put down a 1
and you carry a 1 1 plus 1 is 0 but it
carries a bit over into this sign bit
column oh what a nightmare
what is trying to tell you look is that
the answers to it isn't
when you come to analyze this carefully
it happens largely because the sign bit
is not actually part of the number it's
an add-on extra so this one way I think
we can throw right out the window and
say it may appeal to you as a human to
do it like this but really that is not
going to be easy to build Hardware
around what you want actually in some
sense is to map those negative numbers
differently in other words you map them
top down from the big numbers down to
the little ones in terms of what an
unsigned number would be doing the other
way around and it all is so much easier
what ones complement does is it says
form the negative number by taking a
positive one and inverting every bit if
it's a zero turn it to a one if it's a
one turn it to a zero what that does is
it turns zero into being what would have
been 15 in unsigned yeah but ah since
one on the left is signed and now means
it's a negative number you still have
the two representations of zero problem
you've got zero and you've got minus
zero however look what happens here you
map 0 0 0 1 you flip all the bits this
is a rule to make it negative change 0 0
0 1 into being 1 1 1 0 so that is how
you do minus 1 but what does 1 1 1 0
mean if it were an unsigned number it
means a plus 4 plus 2 is 14 so I've
mapped minus 1 into being 14 I'm at
minus 2 into being 13 this is what I
mean by coming downwards okay now if you
do that well you're part way on the way
to getting a system in which the sign
bit behaves almost normally and that's
what you want to do let us know let me
say yet again this still has the problem
of two representations of 0 which
hardware and software people would
absolutely hate
could you imagine in your java program
if you wrote if i equals equals 0 behind
the scenes a swearing compiler indulges
in lots of bad language saying owing to
the architecture of this machine now now
got to check for plus 0 and minus 0
don't want that you want one
representation of 0 anyway for the
moment this is a step on the way we're
getting there
this is one's complement and let's do
our thing of taking plus 7 and adding
minus 3 well since 7 is a positive
number that is still 0 1 1 1 but we've
now got to add in minus 3 well we look
up what minus 3 is in one's complement
and it is 1 1 0 0 now what I'm saying is
that is a positive representation
because it's got not there as plus 7
this is a negative number clearly it is
it's got 1 in the sign bit position
let's just add them together 1 + 0 is 1
1 + 0 is 1 1 + 1 is 0 but carry 1 1 + 1
is 0 this is in the sign bit position
now but we're still treating it now like
it's an ordinary binary pair of integers
but I've still got 1 plus 1 is 0 and it
will generate a carry the rule in
one's complement arithmetic says the
following treat the sign bit just like a
normal binary addition in that position
but if you generate a carry out from the
sign bit don't throw it away don't
ignore it just bring it back on a
journey round to the right-hand end of
the number and add it in so we then have
naught naught 1 1 + 1 1 + 1 is 0 carry 1
1 + 1 is 0 carry 1 1 + 0 is 1 0 and 0 0
u P that's possible that's the right
answer
now you might say oh well bringing
around that carry bit is just black
magic yeah that would need a more
advanced tutorial explaining exactly why
but it really does work is simply this
it says just treat the sign bit as
normal don't get panicked about it if
you do generate the carry bit just bring
it around to the right hand end and add
it back in ok so we're making real
progress now we've got something which
does give us a right answer but you have
to mess about with carry bits a little
bit wouldn't it be nice if we could get
rid of that effects don't have to worry
about any carry bit and also also what
we really want to solve is this we dump
1 2 zeros okay now there is a big
problem here because if you think about
it you've got some positive numbers 7
negative numbers you've got 2 left over
if you don't have two zeros and you'll
know what 1 0 what's going to happen to
that 16th number as we'll find out now
in the final phase of this story your
leftover number has either got to become
an extra positive number or an astronaut
even umber
so when how do two's complement two's
complement is equivalent to the ones
complement with one added to it let's
just take a sample middle of the range
number plus 3 let's turn it into two's
complement and remember what you do to
do that is you take the binary
representation of 3 you first of all
turn it into one's complement by
flipping the bits
and then you add one let us take plus 3
this is 0 0 1 1 and we want minus 3 in
well first of all we do minus 3 in one's
complement easy you just flip the bits
you go 1 1 0 0 and in two's complement
what do you do you take the ones
complement which you've already got a
new add 1 and you see what happens 1
plus 0 is 1 0 1 1
there's your answer so minus 3 in two's
complement is represented by 1 1 0 1 in
unsigned terms this has now been
represented by 13 1 1 0 1 whereas in
one's complement terms it was 1 1 0 0 it
was represented by 12 so we've shoved at
the whole range down by 1 believe it or
not that now magically gets rid of the 2
zeroes problem just by shifting the
range and if you like this is the
fundamental piece of magic which I think
we can do over here
just consider 0 0 0 0 plus 0 I'm now
going to turn it into minus 0 and with
trepidation because it's probably going
to be some other completely different
bit problem but just look what the rule
says it says do the ones complement
first of all 1 1 1 1 and add one because
two's complement is ones coming up this
one what happens now
1 1 is 0 carry 1 1 on 1 is 0 carry a 1 1
on 1 is 0 carry 1 1 and 1 we're in the
side bit position but we don't panic
it's just like any other 1 on 1 is 0 and
we carry one I'm going to do an
end-around carry no thing you have to
remember in two's complement is that
carries at the left-hand end I just
thrown away and ignore
they do not do an end-around carry like
they did in one's complement it's magic
you just throw the carry bit away and
what you're left with no not-not-not
look at +0 has mapped into looking like
+0 when you take it two's complement
negative that's exactly what you are
after is one representation of zero and
only one but you'll now say aw now come
on you warned us that if you have only
one zero and you if you have and one two
seven that's seven numbers and minus 1
by 7 is 7 times u 1 0 that's only 15
slots taken up what's happening to the
16th slot although it's a 4-bit system
it now ranges from 0 to 7 in positive
but in negative numbers there's the zero
appearing again but right out the bottom
one and three zeros what does that one
represent that and the answer is minus
eight what happens when it goes wrong
well it we've discovered of course that
in two's complement for bit
representation we can go from minus
eight up to plus seven you add anything
within those ranges as we've been doing
like seven plus minus 3 there's no
problem the answer is going to be in
range obviously but if you add together
shall we say plus 7/2 plus 7 and that's
plus 14 and that's too big positive to
be held in four bits equally if you had
I don't know minus 5 to minus 5 that
comes to minus 10 and we can go down as
far as minus 8 but not minus 10 so how
does this show up then we clearly going
to get overflows well I think the answer
is if you look back or think back in the
video to what we were doing when we were
carefully adding 7 2-3 and staying in
range what I didn't point out but
perhaps should have done at the time is
that the carry bit that appeared on the
left you remember you carried out of the
sign position I said oh it's two's
company cuz throw it away yes you can
throw it away but what
you would find is if it's gone wrong is
that there was a carry in to the sign
bit before there was a carry out and the
rule very simply is this is if the carry
in to the sign bit and the carry out to
the sign bits are the same sort of thing
like you're carrying a worn you carry
out a one that's fine or you carry in an
or you carry out a note that's fine but
if they're the opposite way around a
nought gets carried into the side bit
one gets carried out or a one gets
carried in and an August carried out
surefire sign of overflow and that is
exactly what the hardware engineer wants
they don't want to have to start
thinking about the magnitude of the
numbers they want a simple rule about
carry bits which says it's overflowed
and then you set a hardware overflow
indicator just like that this is a
problem it hitters and they would have
embarrassed us slightly in the Ackermann
function video because the those
counters we were setting for all the big
integers we were overflowing all the
time we just weren't checking for it